this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
matt skip our favorite brand from men's
grooming just restocked the new weed
whacker
nose and hair trimmer in my age i'm 36
years old
never used to have this problem before
where my nose hair
would go past my nose this is something
that happens naturally to a lot of
people some people
this happens when they're 15 years old
but in my case
i'm so glad that this came into town
because now
i could keep it under control baby oh my
god it's so good
the weed whacker is water resistant did
you know that
it has a 9000 rpm motor and it also
comes with skin safe technology just
like
the lawnmower so you can quickly and
safely whack those nose weeds anywhere
everywhere i'm doing it right now
getting it all over tiff's tables
for the biggest bang for your buck make
sure you check out
manscape's performance package you get
the weed whacker and
everything you see here from the perfect
package 3.0
you're all in one manskeeping kit go to
manscape.com
jknews for 20 off plus
free shipping we're gonna have the link
in the description box below thank you
to manscape for keeping our pubes
trimmed and
our nose free of weeds oh
it's clean nice
[Music]
yeah how do you do it back and forth
send it send it to casey neistat
send them a cake look at this okay you
kiss it look at that
oh you gotta believe though you caught
it
if you don't you got it oh [ __ ] oh you
oh out of bounds
what happened send it one more time one
more time you want to go get it
you took the kiss away give it one more
send one more all right i'm gonna go i
got another
circuit
[Applause]
nobody saw that [ __ ] i wasn't recording
i saw that i got the perfect view here
it looks perfect
anyways let's take two shots of cuervo
starts playing kiss pawn
dude we created a new sport by the way
oh my gosh his punch his pawn dude
it's only for the boys though we don't
play one for the boys you should
actually have a ball the ping-pong ball
and throw it i bet you if you two do it
together right now we won't not watch
nah but we are but girls edition girls
edition
this is a patreon video of these
contacts these [ __ ] are drunk okay
trunk
[Laughter]
record the best part i think the
camera's got it though
yeah like the camera's got it oh my gosh
the camera's got it anyway
i'm [ __ ] you guys enjoy it right now
let's talk about this we created a new
sport it's called kiss pong it's going
to be the new rage every guy is going to
do it girls can't do it though
yeah girls aren't allowed you guys have
great technique by the way joe says he's
down
you have to believe no i don't want it i
don't want it he can't handle it you
guys are going to mess up my game
okay let me tell you this damn article
ready
so this article here is talking about
these
these five birds who mo moved into
in a british park and
they like picked up their bags and moved
or yeah they moved they picked up their
tiny little
bags little suitcases so cute how did
pigeons get all over the world them
having a little hat too
oh how cute and a little coat somehow
are you like the birds from dumbo
i don't know
anyway they're such haters weren't they
yeah they're like you can't fly oh
never seen that i love them no they're
like
it's not even just that they're like
i've seen all kinds of crazy [ __ ] in
this world
like i seen a [ __ ] leopard on the
unicycle but i've never seen an
elephant fly like it's pretty mean yeah
they're clowning
straight up well you know who else is
bullying these birds as well
all right parrots so they
like i said these yeah these parrots
fluff these birds they
they ended up going to this new park
right and
because of the pandemic a lot of people
are giving up their birds
and they're like wait what oh [ __ ] oh
that's sad
wait they can't feed them corona make
people give up their birth they can't
feed them
or like the fact that they yeah whatever
it is so
they had 20 new birds come into this one
particular park in the same week
they got lazy and so they spent a week
together in quarantine before they ended
up
joining the other the other birds the
birds quarantined
yes and then that's responsible that's
very responsible
there were these five birds that all had
potty mouths they all were like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] probably they don't
tell me which
which bad words and of course they don't
this is the problem with the news today
they don't ask the question we all want
i know that's why we have just kidding
news if we had more staff
and then we can have them ask the real
questions we would train them
to ask and then we would have them go
out and be like what were the birds
saying
and i would have them go into the park
and record the birds going
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i can
tell you their names though
what is it polly it was these five what
was it holly
pollywood a cracker rory polly it was
these five african grey parrots named
billy
elise eric jade and tyson
are they african or they're like
african-american and they use different
curse words and different british
accents yeah i need to know if they're
like they look like this
aren't they like really smart like those
arts are really smart
so they so the way that they discovered
this was that one employee was
walking around and then he overheard
like some employees
just [ __ ] cussing it up and they were
like
and so this this one worker he was
heading over to tell them like
hey man cut that [ __ ] out like you guys
are cursing too much but then he found
out it was these parrots
and they were just they were cursing
with each other and then they were all
laughing and it just sounded like a room
full of teenage boys [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] british accent
oh that was a really good brit you wake
up you bloody hell
people from there are listening and
they're like that is perfect
that was pissed tracy just like dick
trace
wait where's dick tracy from with his
british accent from murray poppins and
how horrible it was
she's talking about uh mom bert from
from
oh i was like wait what i just had your
back it's all good i had your brother
isn't that the actor's name no it's dick
van dyke that's what you say
but it's all good dick tracy the guy in
the yellow yellow
trench but he's a fraud i don't know why
i got him
in coots with carmen san diego there you
go where is she do you guys did you guys
like dick tracy i liked it
i liked it yeah i hadn't seen it i
didn't know so that's why i got it mixed
up
as good as andy griffith that's on my
next movie to watch actually tracy i've
been turning down
great movies those villains were so ugly
yeah they're scary al pacino's in that
movie
and he got nominated for a [ __ ] oscar
from dick tracy for dick tracy
but not all the other scorsese films
well i think
he won for something for like scent of a
woman or something i think wait i'll put
you know never mind
did he win for scarface i don't think he
was even nominated for scarface he's
that's scarface right maybe he was
well you know it's not really important
right now oh no we need to figure this
out what did the parrot say
i don't know i wanna know damn i wish
there was video footage
when i was in london during christmas
time they barely get any sun right
so i went to the park to sit down like
an old person and get some sun and i was
feeding some pigeons
and i was like man no wonder old people
do this [ __ ] it's kind of cool
it is cool but it's also really scary at
the same time what
scary okay okay feeding pigeons are
scary maybe it's scary because i was
like
eight or maybe like younger when i was
doing this but like i went up to um sf
to visit my grandma
and then my grandma gave me a bag of
bread like old bread
and um i went outside i went outside of
her apartment and then i just started
like throwing bread crumbs and a whole
flock of pigeons came
and then i just started crying because i
didn't expect so many pigeons to come
and then later i enjoyed it but it's
scary at first
it was scary you tiptoed in no even even
as an adult
just seen the mona lisa's mona lisa
anyway we were there and so we're
feeding some pigeons and then they just
all
yeah and i it is very overwhelming what
are they all like
no like they land on you and [ __ ] like
because the guy
they have guys around like the birds and
so like they're like putting
feet like the home alone bird lady yeah
and so like
i have photos like she's nice she was
nice i get it
scary at first but then nice like the
old man from the first one
the shovel the mary poppins guy
tracy as well i swear we'll get to the
parrots eventually i teach
kids like trust pedophiles and stuff
or like somebody dangerous well that's
like a really crazy tournament no no
because like you're very different
well it doesn't have to it's just
dangerous people well no you see an old
guy with a shovel and you're like he's
probably good
yeah cause the movie you're like the
movies like yeah
and then you like originally i don't
trust originally my instincts say
run but because the movie taught me that
these guys are actually the good guys
don't judge don't judge a book by a
trouble
you got things like american psycho
coming at the same time so the people
that don't
look like bad people but that wasn't a
children's movie he's saying that
there's
children so we're leading our children
to be wrong
in this situation at the same time we're
leading them to believe that [ __ ]
turtles can speak and do ninja karate
skills well they can but only if they
have mutagen
yeah these paris by the way probably ate
the toxic ooze dude how coincidental is
it in turtles too that the pizza boy
knew kung fu
yeah he's like i know it's not my fight
and then he throws the pizza in the air
he does the coolest kick i've ever seen
in my whole life that i couldn't do it
give me a thousand takes
what is the demographic of people that
usually watch jk news do they like
under the smile bro we got 12 year olds
to 50 year olds okay so
some people for sure know the kingdom
reference they know turtles too they
know the vanilla ice song and it's their
favorite go
ninja go ninja go go ninja go ninja go
yo it's a green machine gonna rock the
town without being seen
you guys remember right yeah i don't
know i just blacked out because you're
too young right you're too young to
remember
go go go are you a donatello am i
i most likely am realistically
a leonardo i thought i was a leonardo
because i liked him but i think i'm
really a michelangelo
leonardo is just a little bit of a dick
but i i respect that he has to be right
anybody who's in that position just kind
of has he's like oh you understand
because you're in that position you're
the dick and kendra's
do you know what you're saying yeah
that's what he relates i wanted
me yes i am hey there's a way to spend
it
but i am circumcised and that has
nothing to do with this
can you guess which turtle i am and we
just met today
but i guess you were donatello do you
guys believe that they just met
that's pretty weird yeah are you serious
you might either be a donatello or a
michelangelo
i'm a raphael no you're you're not a
rival i was a raphael fan but you are
not a rationality i can be a fan but it
doesn't mean that you are remember
raphael is the guy who got them into
every shady dramatic situation you're
the guy that
solves [ __ ] raphael's the guy that
breaks [ __ ] i want to be the break [ __ ]
guy oh well you're not well you might
want to
but it doesn't mean you are yeah like i
want to be leonardo but i think i'm more
of a michelangelo or a casey jones
or i like casey jones i like casey jones
he's so cool i want to be a splinter but
i'm very clearly
uh a leonardo or april yeah
you're really girl yeah you have to be
happy your gender dictates
i wouldn't let my sister be a turtle i'm
like you're a [ __ ] chick you're just
april
hold the camera [ __ ] that's stupid
no i'm the one that they all love so huh
and then the little brothers were always
bebop and rocksteady and all the bad
guys
they had to be the [ __ ] bad guys or
casey jones honestly
sorry dude but if you're not turning if
you had a hockey stick though yeah if
you're not a troll i wanted to be casey
jones
you are casey you are kind of like casey
jones yeah
anyone with a set of weapons in their
[ __ ] golf bag
is sick that's true dude we try to make
ninja turtle weapons like casey jones
like what was the brain dude
the prank crane yeah it could also be a
crazy it wasn't a stomach though he was
a brain inside the stomach
this is a big ogre dude if only i had a
ninja turtles article
gee well we're making it one okay you
know what it's pigeon turtles
so [ __ ] it it's animals that are cursing
i believe that ninja turtles were real
so i went to
my local um what do you call it the
manhole
the the there's two holes
oh we have a video of isaac talking to
this yeah i was talking inside i was
like ninja turtles i know you're down
there
and then my mom's like what the [ __ ] are
you trying to bribe them with pizza
pizza
pizza but i was trying to talk to him
and [ __ ] and then my mom
was like what are you doing out there
and then she's like you're out there for
like hours just talking to the metal
ninja turtles where are you coming i
like their first name you gotta be like
hamato yoshi yes i don't know one kid
who didn't crawl into a [ __ ] sewer
because yeah
he's sticking their head like hey i've
been in many sewers
at the same time that it was a thing so
that was like really really weird i
didn't get to see it
no but all of us went to sewers and all
that and we even found a homeless dude
but we didn't
see ninja turtles damn that's weird but
he thought he was a ninja turtle
he could have been master splinter true
in this guy
no we all ran he was norokosaki
the real bad guy wait so what what's
going on with these okay
but i want to know though like i want
all these birds yeah april and neil
you're here
see i told you i'm april okay so they
get captured they're already staying out
in the park they actually had a had a
timeout
they had to be taken away from the rest
of the parents re-quarantined
influencing
the parrots or whatever teach them and
then and then so
but now they're they seem to have been
reformed
and then now they're joining the rest of
the so they got brainwashed so they got
like taken put somewhere and they
they were given like love words yeah or
clockwork orange they had the
and then brainwashed back what a
reference
yeah this whole time i was a donatello i
didn't even [ __ ] know
you think so i don't even [ __ ] know
dude is donatello gay
wait i'm gay too
[Music]
you